que é da busca, né? Eu eu no começo eu
sofria muito entre meus desejos ainda de
adolescente e entender o que era meu
trabalho, né? Porque, por exemplo, eu
saí ali do eu saí eu saí do do lugar que
eu cresci e fui direto para um palco
onde a galera tava tendo uma expectativa
imensa do show e eu só fazia vídeo pra
internet, né? Tava até brincando que que
tipo assim, eu fazia, começava a cantar
no chuveiro, quando acabava o banho,
acabava meu show, né?
E aí depois tavam colocando para eu
cantar para uma multidão de gente e
tinha que ter 1 hora e meia. Imagina
você treinar no banheiro 1 hora e meia,
acabou a água do mundo, né?
>> Acabou. [risadas]
>> O show era de 10 minutos, né? No máximo.
>> É. Não, o show era de 5 minutinhos ali e
tal.
E é, às vezes eu eu, por exemplo, você
falou do Bruno, o Bruno comprou um
videogame para mim, um Play 5 e tal, e
esse videogame eu queria jogar, eu dava
para ele para cima e para baixo, mas eu
queria jogar e tinha show à noite e tal,
às vezes era dois shows. Então, no
segundo show, por não ter eh pegado
aquelas horinhas que eu tava jogando e e
ter descansado, eu acabava ficando um
pouco rouco e tal. Então, por exemplo,
eh, demorou um tempo por um tempo,
demorou um tempo para eu para eu eu me
acostumar, eu ter um hábito bom assim
com a música para para porque tudo a
gente tem que construir, né? Construir
bons hábitos e tal. E eu acho que, tipo
assim, ano passado eu saindo de de eu
saindo do do show da virada, toquei em
Macapá, eu poxa, eu fiquei muito feliz
por ter aquele show na virada e tal.
Fiquei muito feliz porque essa acho que
você vai entender no final eu tava
tocando com Alceu e Alceu falou de
música comigo, falou que tinha gostado
da música palco. E por mais que eu
tivesse voltando um lugar difícil ali
longe, poxa, eu tracei uma meta assim,
eu anotei no meu meu bloco de nota assim
que eu queria melhorar algumas coisas,
tipo a questão de entender sobre gestão
financeira, a questão de de fazer uma
própria festa, de tentar colocar alguma
música no top 10 e tal, embora, tipo
assim, eh, seja difícil qualquer
qualquer objetivo que a gente tenha, mas
eu tentar ir em alguma direção, porque
eu achava É, é, eu precisava às vezes de
algumas informações que foram muito
preciosas para mim, assim, de quando
lançar, de por lançar, de o que é eh de
o que é que a gente representa assim na
música às vezes, porque a gente às vezes
fica sem norte assim, eu me vejo muitas
vezes sozinho no quarto de hotel e não
converso sobre isso. Então, eu tive
pessoas que que eh me ajudaram a
entender, porque, por exemplo, a gente
tá hoje conversando sobre eh indicação
ao Grêmio, essas coisas assim na nas
primeiras vezes, tipo, não é você
entender que que foi sorte e tal, não,
dizer: "Poxa, a gente não conseguiu
dessa vez, mas o que é que a gente
precisa fazer da próxima?"
>> Eh, e e tentar construir isso e tentar
chegar lá,
>> evoluir sempre. Exato. Porque eu lembro
quando eu tava voltando ano passado do
do Grêmio Latino, eu encontrei o o
o MC MC, ele falou, ele é
um cara bem mais velho, ele falou: "Ó,
João, eu escutei seu álbum agora e
queria perguntar se você não tem, por
que você não faz uma música que venha do
seu coração e tal, porque, tipo assim,
eu tava fazendo muito a mesma coisa, né,
o mesmo piseiro e tal, embora eu ame
fazer o que eu faça, embora eu ame
piseiro e aí aquilo me pegou. assim.
Então, pessoas me fizeram começar a
pensar. Então, é bom quando a gente tá
vivendo num ambiente onde nem sempre as
opiniões são iguais, assim, onde as
pessoas fazem você pensar, você eh se
questionar. Então, essas pessoas foram
muito importantes. Assim, a gente tá
aqui num lugar onde nesse nesse estúdio
aqui, onde onde o Cald, um grande amigo,
eu posso falar abertamente assim, que é
uma das pessoas importantes para esse
meu desenvolvimento. E eu acho que que,
tipo, quando a gente consegue eh estar
entre as pessoas
e a gente consegue eh eh
expressar o o nosso amor assim ao nosso
trabalho, assim, a gente chega em algum
lugar. Então, tipo, foi escutando essas
pessoas, foi tendo esses amigos assim
por perto.
>> Era uma humildade também, né, João?
Porque que o cara quando ele é vira
artista e vira um artista nacional igual
você, às muit das vezes ele dá uma
vislumbrada ali e começa a não escutar
também. Aí que começa a queda também,
né? Então você sempre foi um cara que
não só escutava como também pedia
conselhos também. E isso você foi
absorvendo absorvendo
plantou esses anos todos aí, esses dois,
tr anos aí, os últimos três anos tava
plantando de uma forma bem mais direta,
uma forma bem mais e concentrada e agora
tá colhendo o que você plantou, né,
velho? Eu acho que é basicamente isso.
>> Mas tem, mas aquela aquela O que é o que
é um artista nacionalmente conhecido? Eu
acho que um artista nacionalmente
conhecido é unanimamente conhecido. Eu
acho que eu sou conhecido em todos os
lugares do Brasil assim e tal. Então,
por exemplo, mas o que é que eu quero
comunicar no som e tal? Por exemplo, a
primeira vez que eu fui a Porto Alegre
foi a convite do Luan Santana e tal e
tipo assim, ali eu conheci um mundo
completamente diferente, assim, que
parecia que eu tava em outro país mesmo,
parecia que eu tava num lugar muito
estrangeiro mas
>> são outros países mesmo, acho que é
muito grande o Brasil, né? Aí eu eu, por
exemplo, uma dupla sertaneja estava
tocando antes de mim e eu fiquei
assustado com a força que a galera
cantava as música e eu digo, como é que
eu nunca escutei essa música e ela é
cantada com tanta força assim? E tipo
assim, a primeira vez que o Dominguinho
teve a data no Porto Alegre, eu falei:
"Poxa, eu vou retornar aquele lugar,
será que a galera vai saber minha música
lá?" Ou então quando a gente foi em
Curitiba e tipo assim, a galera a galera
não só pediu o dominguinho quando ela
como ela botou no meu coração assim que
tinha dado certo. Eu fiquei tipo em
choque assim as pessoas falando daquilo
no no nos aeroportos, a galera que tava
indo no voo comigo falando. Então
fiquei, meu Deus, velho, que que Então,
tipo assim, a gente, eu, por exemplo, eu
tenho, eu eu acredito que eu tenho um
uma missão assim, porque foi deixado de
herança por para mim e para todos os
outros forrozeiros, assim, de que outras
pessoas façam forró, escrevam letras,
acreditem na nas poesias que que que são
feitas no nosso lugar. Então que a gente
deixe essa essa chama acesa assim,
porque, por exemplo, eu sou um um
indivíduo hoje e tal e mais na frente
serão outras pessoas, outros talentos.
Então, tipo, a música ela precisa que
que o movimento seja muito muito rico,
assim, muito verdadeiro. Então, tipo, eu
tô eu tô muito feliz de poder, é, de
poder falar, de poder me comunicar, de
apresentar pessoas, embora eu não acho
que seja que seja o melhor assim, que
essa geração tem muita gente boa, tal,
tem o Tacísio, aí tem uma turma massa aí
que eu quero ajudar, que depois eu posso
até falar,
>> mas
>> tipo assim, que a gente mantenha sempre
a a chama, tem um menino que chama Juan
Vaqueirinho, meu irmão, o menino é
pequeno
>> que ele tava no na Globo esse final de
semana. Aquele menino é um fenômeno.
>> Aí, tipo assim, eu encontrei com e eu eu
gravei
>> ela artista, né, João?
>> Não, eu gravei com ele no DVD. Eu chamei
ele pro DVD e eu pedi para cantar.
Espere minha mãe, estou voltando.
Chitãozinho chororó e tal. E aí eu Ele
não vai aprender a música. Poxa, eu
fiquei preocupado porque ele não foi pro
ensaio.
Ele me vem e posta, ele posta de manhã
cantando a música, meu irmão. Eu fiquei,
eu digo, falei a banda, banda, é o
seguinte, eu não vou cantar. E e eu
cantei a música sozinho e eu fiquei, tá
faltando alguma coisa. E faltava ele,
porque na hora que ele abre a voz para
cantar, velho, tipo, eu fiquei ele, ele
por que ele não tá cantando, ele calado,
ele só esperando enquando ele solta a
voz. Eh, tipo assim, dá um brilho, né?
>> Não, eu eu, por exemplo, ali tinha
muitas pessoas, mas eu vi a eu senti
assim uma energia tão forte assim
naquela hora que eu falei: "Meu Deus,
velho, eh tem alguma coisa acontecendo
aqui e e minhas palavras nunca vão poder
explicar". Aí, tipo assim, a minha
reação foi cair assim e ele cantando
assim com aquela com aquela voz forte.
Então, por exemplo, eu não quero gravar
com com um menino desse e, tipo assim,
aproveitar do talento dele e aproveitar
do momento assim e deixar por isso
mesmo. Poxa, eu já comecei a pensar logo
em plano para para poxa, como é que eu
posso ajudar ele depois disso? Será que
eu não posso falar com o parceiro e tal?
>> E aí eu vi que ele chorou assim quando
viu o Leno que é o L7 e tal, digo: "E
aí, Leno, você não quer gravar com o
menino não e tal?"
já começa a tentar fazer umas pontes, já
começa a tentar deixar alguma coisa eh
pro futuro dele assim, porque o nosso
futuro como forrozeiro depende de um
talento assim, né? Não,
>> com certeza.
>> Porque, por exemplo, no sertanejo eh eh
e na e na, vamos dizer assim, na música
caipira em si, que é a nossa música,
assim, eh eh a gente precisa muito do
coração, né? São músicas que são feitas
com muito coração. Então, tipo assim,
hoje o menino tá com um coração cheio de
alegria pela música, então não quero ver
ele se frustrando com isso. Eu quero que
ele veja aquele clipe comigo e digo:
"Poxa, nesse dia começou uma coisa da
hora na minha vida e tal e a essa
certeza pra mãe dele, essa certeza
para". Então, é mais ou menos essa,
velho, a missão. Acho que eh eh o nosso
papel aqui é só tentar ser algum
instrumento de luz aí mesmo, porque
final
a gente não vai conseguir sozinho, né? É
desse jeito.
>> É, cara, quando o artista ele ele
consegue colocar dentro da cabeça esse
pensamento aí, é porque de fato ele
evoluiu muito, não só profissional, mas
espiritualmente também. Porque é muito
isso, né, João? E quando você fala que
você recebeu a dica de porque às vezes o
artista ele entra no automático, né,
João? também. E e em música não é
automático, você tem que falar do
coração mesmo. quando teve essa mudança
do coração, as coisas começaram a mudar
também eh profissionalmente.